now we're going to begin this hour with
another exclusive interview with one of
the greatest athletes of all time Serena
Williams the tennis Legend is showing
off a new Talent golf in this year's
Michelob Ultra Super Bowl commercial
here's a look
[Music]
well we're waiting
County
only on CBS mornings we sat down with
Serena Williams for a wide-ranging
conversation about tennis and her family
what's she doing these days and we
caught up with her and her husband
Alexis Ohanian on their Farm in Florida
for a glimpse of their lives or her life
specifically after tennis
[Music]
what does it take to get Serena Williams
to do a Super Bowl commercial well it's
not okay so first of all I have to have
a genuine like for the product right
second of all like what are you doing
outside of that is there something
special and that's what I love about
Michelob Ultra they really are really
animate about making sure there's gender
equality when it comes Equity I should
say when it comes to male and female in
particular women athletes and Men
athletes so this is reflected in that
commercial it is reflected in that
commercial and this is the second year
in a row that they have the same number
of female athletes or women athletes as
they do male athletes when I looked at
the commercial Serena and the way you
swung the golf club and I remember the
Vogue letter and you said you're not
retiring you're transitioning and
evolving is this your way of telling us
you're evolving into golf because we
certainly had the outfit ready I I'm 100
not evolving into golf I last met up
with Serena Williams at her final U.S
open she has changed the game in so
you know the day after the US Open and
you wake up and you're you're done with
tennis as we know it in that form what
was that morning like because I woke up
that morning thinking I wonder what
Serena's doing I wonder how Serena is
feeling that's a really good question
I've never no one's asked me that yet
um I was actually not very happy at all
not be just because of the result I was
there to keep going and to keep winning
and
um yeah it wasn't it was more or less
like I can't believe I let that match go
more than anything you know obviously it
was a great moment and a great memory
and I've never felt
I don't feel like I've left anything but
I just felt like what could have done
better that day
when Serena revealed her decision to
step away from tennis and Vogue last
year she wrote this if I have to choose
between building my tennis resume and
building my family I choose the latter
she also shared that her daughter
Olympia wants to be a big sister to this
day she's like now she prays praise
foreign
she's like and the other day she's like
everyone has a brother or a sister but
me and I'm like Olivia I'm working on it
mommy worked a little too long in tennis
so stay a little longer than expected
but yeah and so now that you've you've
it's been a minute since you've been off
the tennis court you said you still like
to win you still our competitor yeah so
what does winning look like to you these
days
um winning to me
just picking out the best deals to
invest in you know and the tennis
champions Venture Capital firm it's
called Serena Ventures is focused on
funding founders with diverse
backgrounds we need people like me we
need women writing the checks because I
really am a big believer and like
attracts like investing is something
Serena and her husband Alexis Ohanian
founder of venture capital firm 776 and
social site Reddit have in common these
days a couple spends their time here at
their South Florida Farm where they grow
fruits and vegetables and raise chickens
Serena do you want to pick one up uh
I've never touched them a mini horse at
their daughter Olympia named Daisy and a
steer named Antonio Enrique Cortez uh
leche Serena that's the name of the cow
I missed a couple of them Antonio who
Antonio for Antonio Banderas okay
Enrique for Enrique Iglesias Cortez
because it was why we were watching the
Spy Kids movie okay yeah and that was
the last name it looks like it's movie
so I let the kids
[Laughter]
Alexis I don't know if you know this the
first time when I heard about you Serena
said I said oh how's it going who are
you dating she goes oh I'm dating this
tech nerd you've probably never heard of
him do you remember she said I'm dating
this tech nerd you've probably never
heard him I said well what's his name
and she said your name I go I know him
he's he's great he's actually one of the
guys I appreciate you about you for
me what makes this work Alexis for you
and Serena what makes this work for you
he is able to handle me
are you allowed to handle
no I'm very easy and I'm very relaxed
and chill but I'm somehow super intense
and I like things
really perfect why does it work for you
this relationship because I knew I have
met someone that I was never going to
outgrow and more importantly I knew I
had met someone who was always going to
explicitly believe me sometimes or
implicitly challenge me to be better
she's a ride or die and you all don't
see a lot of it because thankfully it'll
do my work in public but I she's right
or dad oh the thousand percent oh my God
yes it's so lovely to sit here at the
place you call the farm the tennis court
is right there what do you think when
you look at a tennis court now I was
wondering yeah in this particular tennis
court I see me out there I see me
training I see me grinding so you can
look at it Serena not feel a pain of oh
I feel a relief when I look at the court
sometimes because
I feel like I'm so happy I don't have to
train for two hours a day I feel more
pain
um just like looking at old pictures
yeah look at all the pictures are
championships or something like that I'm
like oh I miss that or that's when I
feel like different because the door
opened just a sliver uh it's hard to say
I would say no for for now no because
it's just
I've literally given my whole life to
tennis and it's time for me to give my
life to something else yeah and then my
dad is like Serena you should play one
more slant you should play like two more
Grand Slams or and I'm like Dad like
stop stop this is not but you know I
came across some old video I'm going to
run in this piece it's the sweetest
piece of video but don't hit that racket
on the ground
I was smashing my racket even back you
can play tomorrow next year and the year
after that
is important
the family is important in your home you
shouldn't be out here getting getting
disgusted because of a tennis ball right
oh that's so sweet your little girl
voice yeah and that's why you wanted
people to see King Richard because we
did get to see him in another light we
totally this is literally the light that
that was the truth King Richard was
absolutely true I know and then King
Richard had that moment at the Oscars
what did you feel about that I thought
it was such an um an incredible film and
I feel that there was an incredible film
after that with Quest love
that kind of was overshadowed it was
overshadowed but I also feel that
I've been a position where I've been
under a lot of pressure and I've made a
tremendous amount of mistakes and I'm
the kind of person that's like I've been
there I've made a mistake it's not the
end of the world we're on perfect and
we're all human and let's just be kind
to each other and I think that's so
that's often forgotten a lot you tweeted
recently allowing yourself to relax was
harder than you ever imagined yeah it's
hard to relax for you it's so hard for
me to relax I don't know how to relax
really I literally don't like I am I
have to schedule it in my schedule
dude I'm not kidding I have to schedule
relax or I won't do it and I have it at
my schedule in a while so I need to put
it back in there
well we were totally relaxed hanging out
with with Serena and her family that day
she also says if she'd been a man and
was in the health that she's in she'd
probably still be playing tennis because
she loves it so much but family is also
a very top priority but I love that
moment with her dad I think it showed a
different side of him that many people
didn't really understand Richard
Williams she's totally in love with her
father and he's still calling and giving
her tips about what she should do and
how she should do it but she's very
happy they're very happy together and I
loved Alexis's answer too he he finally
met someone that he couldn't outgrow
yeah isn't that nice I'm gonna text that
to Katie later today yeah that you look
more in a partner I thought it was very
they seem to have a nice Rhythm they do
and they're working on she says we're
working on it we're working on it and
when it's when it's time she will share
that too I like the name she came up
with uh for the cows as well very
creative with the Spanish accent too not
bad not bad nicely done all right